Then you get to real assimilated. What's up with this, dude.
I I've been seeing this thing around
a family Dutch family waiting for end of time,
found in secret room. K not secret anymore.
Police discovered a hidden room at a remote farmhouse in the Netherlands. Cod,
how many remote farmhouses are in the Netherlands and how many of them have a
secret room? Dude,
every farmhouse in the Netherlands is a secret
room.
A family who spent nine years on a farm waiting for the end of time,
quote have been discovered by police in the Netherlands.
After one of them turned up at a local pub reports say, I mean, you know,
so Netherlandish local pub Amanda,
58 and six young adults aged 18 to 25 were living at a farm in the
province of Drenthe.
Netherlands ends with a ne course S neither outlandish
of the family were found after the eldest of the children ordered a
beer at a bar in a nearby,
a nearby village of ruin or Wald
Sonetta garlands Drenthe and ruiner walled, eh,
snare Overland, nobody with Brown hair has ever been there. Only blonde.
He then told staff he needed help.
Broadcaster RDV Drenthe reported heir Netherland.
Hey, I need help. Hey. I mean, dude ordered a beer and then asked for help.
Amen. You've been in a secret room for nine years. Hey dude. Ask for,
help me immediately then get liquored up.
We found six people living in a small space in the house, which could be locked,
but wasn't a basement. Ah, roundabout say it different.
So Netherland. Yeah.
We found six people living in a small space in the house, which could be locked,
but wasn't a basement. Hey man, guess what? It's a basement.
So you go downstairs, right? So this is what it is not a basement,
but you can go into the main area, walk into the house,
then you go kind of in the back area. Then you,
there are steps you traveled to downstairs, then there's a door.
And then inside that door that can be locked, opens up. And then it is a room,
not a basement. Do you mean, well that's a basement. No, it wasn't.
Well, what do you mean? It's down. It's under the it's under the house, right?
Yes, it was right. So it was a basement. No, it's a room, not a basement.
K. How is it not a basement? Because it's what I'm saying. Just,
just what you have to do is trust us butters. Shut the up. You're an in cell,
the older man has been arrested natch. According to the family,
he is the father of the six children say, please got props.
It was not clear whether they had been there. Voluntary, clear to me,
been held captive police added police are dumb.
The eldest son was not there at the time.
Police told the BBC local reports described man as a handyman called Joseph B,
who was a rich R and B singer.
Bro.
Last name. Otherwise you're a RNB singer who is originally from Austria,
Joseph B.
So an R and B singer in the nineties and did one song with Tupac.
And that was his biggest hit.
His number one hit, not a basement. Oh,
it's so trapped. I've never seen anything like it.
Local mayor, Roger de Groot told reporters.
Roger de Groot.
He revealed that some of the family had not been registered locally and is,
and also indicated that the 58 year old was not the father.
K K the public broadcaster said that the family had been living in
isolation waiting for the end of time, cement, a props bar owner,
Chris Wester, beak.
Sonata.
Lynn described how a man had come in, ordered five beers and drunk them. Oh,
wow.
Hey, what's up, dude? Can I get, um, five beers please? Well, yeah.
Do you want to order them one at a time? Yeah, it doesn't matter. Yeah. Cool.
Hey, take one. Go, go, go, go, go, go then. Let me get another one and go,
go get a dog duck. Hey dude. Let me get my third beer. Oh yeah, sure.
That's fine. Yeah. Could I get my fourth year please? Yeah, sure. Go, go, go,
go, go. Hi. I'd really like another beer. Oh, that's a lot, but okay. Okay. Go,
go, go, go, go, go. So anyway, I've been captured for nine years and um,
I'm waiting for the end of time in a secret room,
not a basement over in a farmhouse in the Netherlands.
[Inaudible]
tell him before the first beer.
Oh my God. Look at this bar owner, Chris Wester beaks,
and Adelyn described how a man had come in order five beers in drunk thin.
Then I had a chat with him and he revealed he had run away and needed help.
Then we called the police. He added,
he had long hair, a dirty beard, wore old clothes and look confused.
That's literally everybody in the Netherlands has anybody in the
Netherlands not looked confused or had a dirty beard and long hair and word on
clothes, dude, they're still on them, uh, cross colors. You know what I mean?
They're still on union. Uh, what was that,
they're still on a Miller's that they were submitted where Miller's outpost.
Oh dude. Oh, every fifth person in the Netherlands.
Whereas Miller's outpost is still yeah. What?
I don't see the problem and they have good deals and they are still everywhere.
So
I got ginkgo jeans from them and to have a cross color shirt is fine for
Marisol. Outposts really is good for a lot of back to school stuff.
Their nose up was killed it on the back to school.
I literally just found out it was a chain. I thought it was only a
place in locking you out of that. You'd go to, for back to school. Anyway, he,
uh, he said he had never been to school. Ah,
and hadn't been to the barber for nine, eight years. Hey guy go.
He said he had brothers and sisters who lived at the farm.
He said he was the oldest and wanted to end the way they were living. K
officers visited them, carried out asserts.
They discovered a hidden staircase behind a cupboard in a living room. Well,
I mean, why are they
so intent on making sure that we think that this is not a basement
who gives a? Like what happened in basements,
in the Netherlands that they're like, ah, we don't.
That's like Germans with the, they're not,
not liking to talk about world war II. No, not a basement. No, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no.
Wow.
Local postman said he had never delivered a leather there.
It's actually pretty strange not to come to think about it. Oh, Oh wow.
Check this out. You thought everything else was net Netherland. Check this out.
The local postman said he had never just wait till the end
of this sentence.
This is the most you've ever heard. This is the most Netherlands,
the Netherlands sentence you'll ever hear in your life.
And the first 80% of the sentence isn't even at all,
any Netherland. That's how Netherland it is at the end of the sentence,
check it out. The local postman said he had never delivered a letter,
a letter there. It's actually pretty strange. Now I come to think about it.
He told a gleaming Dagblad news website,
Egg limine. Dagblad
Do it one time. I saw a comment on my podcast. He was like, I like his standup,
but this podcast sucks. What the? I don't get it. It's not even funny.
All it is is him making sounds.
Uh, anyway, Jesus Christ,
these names yesterday,
some reported to us that they were worried about the living conditions of people
in a house in boudin. Who's her wig in row. I mean, come on, dude.
They're just with us at this point. I get it.
After years of searching, I found my sister next to her. Okay.
Anyway, that's wild, man. How many, how many years would it take for how many?
I mean, how many, how long would it take for me to be in a basement or,
sorry, not a basement Netherlands, but for me to be there to, uh,
to where I would be like, Kay, I actually think maybe not the,
it won't be the end of time anytime soon. So let's just go outside.
I'm real hungry. And I want to get my haircut. Maybe
Four days, no four hours.
I'll do this the end of times. Yeah, dude, for real,
you go downstairs and then you're like, all right, actually it's probably okay.
The quality of life isn't worth living down here in this basement.
So let's just go cause there's and sucking to get done.